[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
jetzt so kurz vor Weihnachten wird mal
wieder Zeit für Cheesecake und zwar für
Cheesecake am Stiel Cheesecake Sticks
und ich habe mir gedacht da packe ich
doch jetzt einen winterliche
weihnachtlichen Kuchen später wird es
ganze wie gesagt an so einen Stil dran
gesteckt der Kuchen und dann in
Kuvertüre getaucht und schön dekoriert
und ich finde dass es einfach eine
schöne Idee einen Kuchen mal anders
anzurichten und vor allem kann man so
ein Kuchenstück auch wunderschön
verpacken und verschenken und es ist
nicht gleich so eine riesen Kuchen den
man dann tagelang ist wobei sein muss
Käsekuchen geht immer Käsekuchen bleibt
mir übrig Käsekuchen mag auch eigentlich
jeder also ich kenne jetzt keinen Test
nicht mag aber so hat man einfach was
schönes festliches weihnachtliches und
einfach noch was anderes und da werde
ich jetzt erstmal den Käsekuchen backen
und wenn ihr euch zeitlich ein bisschen
einteilen wollt dann könnt ihr am 1 Tag
den Käsekuchen backen und dann kühl
stellen und am nächsten Tag einfach
dekorieren dann geht es wirklich fix und
wirklich sehr einfach zu ich zeige mich
mal dazu Karten für den Mürbeteig denn
das ist ein Käsekuchen mit Boden für den
Mürbeteig nämlich 120g Zucker 240 g
kalte Butter 360 g Mehl da könnt ihr
Weizenmehl 405 oder Dinkelmehl 630
nehmen etwas als Vanilleextrakt und ein
Ei
und da achtet jetzt einfach drauf dass
die Butter schön kalt ist und verknetet
alles ganz schnell zu einem Mürbeteig
[Musik]
wenn sich beide so ein bisschen
verbunden hat gebt ihr einfach alle
Zutaten dazu falls ihr keine
Küchenmaschine habt dann könnt ihr den
Teig natürlich auch mit der Hand
verkneten besser ist aber dann ein
Handrührgerät weil Mürbeteig einfach
nicht warm werden sollte und deswegen
achtet ihr da einfach drauf aber wir
stellen den sowieso gleich kalt von
daher ist alles erlaubt
einfach kurz verkneten
[Musik]
und jetzt sind sie dann mit drei Fakten
auf einen Teller am besten dann bisschen
flach drücken und auf jeden Fall jetzt
erstmal kühl stellen für etwa eine halbe
Stunde
Steckling gleich einfach mit so einem
Silikondeckel ab und kann in der
Zwischenzeit aber auch schon mal die
käsekuchenmasse herstellen und da ist
jetzt auch ganz praktisch die Schüssel
braucht jetzt nicht auswaschen ihr
bekommt sie einfach weiter
ein bisschen Geschirr sparen und ich
richte ihr kurz die Zutaten her und zeig
dir euch und es kommt jetzt im
Kühlschrank
dafür nehme ich 150 g weiche Butter 200
Gramm Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt fünf
Eier die sind bereits auf Raumtemperatur
750 g Magerquark Lebkuchengewürz habe
ich jetzt zwei Teelöffel 50 Gramm Stärke
jeweils 200 g Schmand und Sahne und
etwas Zitronensaft und hier gibt dir
jetzt die weiche Butter in die
Rührschüssel ich weiß manche sind immer
verwirrt wann soll die Butter
was hat geklingelt
bei uns egal wir machen weiter als er
nichts gehört
sein soll bei mir einfach immer kalt und
ansonsten eigentlich
dazu
egal ich tue so als hätten wir nichts
gehört
und wenn die Masse dann weiß cremig ist
könnt ihr auch schon den Quark dazugeben
bei uns ist heute richtig Halligalli man
bei uns klingeln Sie einfach wir haben
keine Ahnung wo es klingelt denn alle
Geräte sind lautlos
schönes Terrarium
ein Fall für X Factor
ja wir haben hier immer
okay ok ich muss erklären in jedem
normal Haushalt klingelt aber wir haben
ja eine Funktion da kann man die Klingel
aus machen haben wir auch in der alten
Wohnung kacken wenn so dann gut wir uns
nicht gemacht wenn es Baby schlafen hat
werden halt gemacht wenn wir gedreht
haben und dann hat man es halt nicht
klingeln hören aber jetzt haben wir so
alles aus und es klingelt trotzdem und
wir verstehen es nicht weil eigentlich
klingelt halt nicht
naja wir werden es rausfinden
Quark Dame die stärkere rein
ach Lebkuchengewürz könnte auch direkt
mit rein geben
alles schön verrühren
und dann gebe ich gleich nacheinander
die Eier dazu immer eins nach dem
anderen so dass es nicht blocke ich
werde mich gerinnt und alles schön homo
gehen wird
[Musik]
und jetzt ist im Prinzip schon geschafft
jetzt einfach noch den Rest Zutaten
dazugeben kurz einrühren und fertig und
dann warte ich noch ein paar kurze
minuten bis der Mürbeteig soweit ist und
kann dann den Käsekuchen schon
zubereiten
jetzt runter brauche ich nur so ein
bisschen was
und fertig aber ich nehme zum Spritze
Canon mg
[Musik]
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr den Käsekuchen
normal groß machen oder er macht zwei
kleine Käsekuchen so 20 cm Durchmesser
bin ich ganz praktisch weil dann
wirklich auch zwei backringe auf einem
Blech passen ich habe zum einen mehrere
Stücke und die Stücke sind auch nicht so
riesig wie bei so einer 26er Torte das
heißt das ganze wird einfach auch nicht
zu mächtig und jetzt nehmt ihr euch den
Mürbeteig
und formt immer so kleine ja so
Würstchen die drücke ich an den Rand und
sie so den Rand des Käsekuchens hoch und
den Rest drücke ich dann in die Mitte
auf dem Boden und daran soll der so
ungefähr 3 cm hoch sein
[Musik]
den Rest habe ich dann zu einer Kugel
drück sie flach so ein bisschen vorher
dann geht's einfacher und dann hier
drinnen schön flach drücken und wenn es
doch mal kleben sollte einfach ein
bisschen Mehl an die Finger und schön
glatt machen und wichtig ist es einfach
dass der Käsekuchen Rand nicht so krasse
Berge auf weiß sondern dass er relativ
gleichmäßig ist
[Musik]
und wenn ihr das habt kommt jetzt die
käsekuchenmasse rein einfach schön
gleichmäßig den Ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 170 Grad Ober-Unterhitze
und dann backt der Käsekuchen ist ein
bisschen kleiner so ungefähr 45 Minuten
danach schalte ich dann Ofen aus lass
ihn im Ofen so ein bisschen abkühlen für
eine halbe Stunde dann nehme ich ihn
raus und nachdem er Raumtemperatur
angenommen hat komm dafür mindestens
zwei Stunden in den Kühlschrank damit
ich ihn später schön schneiden kann
[Musik]
jetzt ist mein Käsekuchen abgekühlt da
war jetzt aus dem Kühlschrank geben auch
ich kann ihn jetzt raus lösen das
solltet ihr wirklich auch Wert drauf
legen dass der schön kalt ist damit ihr
ihn gut schneiden könnt
das und jetzt schneidet ihr die beiden
Kuchen einfach in Stücke gleichmäßige
Stücke ich nehme jetzt auch deswegen
meinen torteneinteiler
[Musik]
und ich schneide dir jeweils zwölf
Stücke draus
ich mache das Messer auch immer wieder
sauber damit der Kuchen einfach perfekt
geschnitten wird
der riecht so lecker ich würde ihn am
liebsten jetzt schon essen
[Musik]
und am besten nehmt ihr euch sie jetzt
so kleine Holzstäbchen Eisstiele steckt
sich hier hinten mittig rein und dann
wird der Käsekuchen eingefroren und zwar
so dass die Stücke nicht
aneinanderkleben also wirklich bis dann
auseinander ziehen und dann einfrieren
so dass der Kuchen also er muss nicht
komplett durchgefroren sein aber er
sollte so ein bisschen angefroren sein
wegen Käsekuchen mit ich auf eine
Tortenplatte legen oder auf ebenso einen
tortenretter dann könnt ihr sogar
schauen dass die Stile einfach schön
gleichmäßig reingesteckt werden als ich
guck einfach dass hier am Rand alles so
denselben Abstand hat und jetzt sehe ich
die ein bisschen auseinander damit sie
dann beim Einfrieren nicht
aneinanderkleben
einfach immer so jedes zweite Stück raus
perfekt
und dann ab mit euch in den
Gefrierschrank und
ich kann nicht sagen jetzt ist die
meiste Arbeit getan und jetzt kommt der
spaßige Part
jetzt ist er Käsekuchen bereit und es
kann wieder eskaliert werden also nicht
erschrecken es sieht jetzt ein bisschen
viel aus
es ist auch viel okay es ist also was
jetzt machen werde ich hatte zwei
verschiedene Teesorten nehmen und zwar
nehme ich die Callebaut Kuvertüre einmal
in Karamell und in weiß und ich sage ich
mal noch kurz die restlichen Zutaten als
Topping könnt ihr wirklich nehmen was
immer euch gefällt optisch dazu passt
vielleicht aus der kleine Doktor
Kügelchen oder Süßigkeiten die euch
gefallen ich guck mal nur vielleicht
hole mir noch Giotto irgendwoher je
nachdem ob ich ja mal gucken ich sage
Dich erstmal was ich hier hab ich habe
hier schonmal Kuvertüre 900 g dann nehme
ich jetzt einmal die Karamell Kuvertüre
und eine weiße Kuvertüre dann als
Topping habe ich hier gehackte
Haselnüsse diesen bereits gerüstet hier
die crispr das auch in Weiß & Karamell
ein paar Lotus Kekse weiße Perlen her
diese süßen Gingerbread Männer und die
kleinen Sternchen und zwar ist es und
streudekor der richtig schön ist denn
das ist doch keine Sternchen diese
goldstars und die sind einfach nicht aus
Zucker sondern auch so eine Art
Esspapier und die kann man ganz leicht
streuen und die sind echt schön also die
kann man als Topping für was alles
nehmen die sind unserem kleinen Gläschen
und ich habe dieses Döschen schon seit
ein paar Monaten muss ich sagen das sind
über 3000 Sterne drin und die sind halt
echt ergäbe ich weiß nur ganz klein und
so ganz zart sind also das ist schon
eine große Mengen die man da hat
Gott jetzt werde ich aber zuerst einmal
die Kuvertüre schmelzen und die können
Sie entweder über dem warmen Wasserbad
machen mit der impfmethode die wenn dich
auch gleich an andy Kuvertüre sollte auf
jeden Fall temperiert werden damit
später die cheese Steak Steaks werden
sie in die Kuvertüre getaucht werden
keinen ground er bekommt dass die
Kuvertüre auch schön fest ist und
schönen Knacks bekommt und deswegen
verwendet ihr dies mit rote das heißt
zwei Drittel habe ich jetzt hier schon
drin ein Drittel ist hier und ich
schmeiße jetzt erstmal diese zwei
Drittel und es macht dir entweder auf
dem warmen Wasserbad oder können auch
die Mikrowelle verwenden und ich mache
das heute einfach in der Mikrowelle weil
ich auch zwei große Mengen habe und
macht es jetzt erst mal für eine Minute
rein bei ungefähr sechs bis 800 Watt
dann rühren und dann einfach immer
wieder so etwa zwanzig Sekunden
nachstellen immer wieder rühren bis die
Kuvertüre geschmolzen ist passt aber auf
dass es nicht zu heiß wird ok die
Kuvertüre ist jetzt geschmolzen und die
ist jetzt auf ungefähr 50 Grad erwärmt
jetzt gebe ich das restliche Drittel
dazu und die sorgt dafür dass ich die
Kuvertüre jetzt wieder herunter kühle so
dass ich später einfach die perfekte
weiter Verarbeitungstemperatur habe
jetzt ist wichtig einfach nur zu rühren
damit alles schön schmilzt und wenn sie
jetzt zu stark abkühlt werde ich jetzt
gleich noch mal das ganze auf Wasserbad
setzen oder können kurz in die
Mikrowelle stellen oder auch mit einem
Heißluftfön so ein bisschen erwärmen
aber jetzt ist wirklich wichtig erstmal
runterkühlen
und falls ihr generell noch Fragen zu
Schokolade habt oder zu Kuvertüre dann
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare
denn Anfang nächsten Jahres möchte ich
dann direkt ein Schokoladen basic video
machen und dann kann ich da alle Fragen
von euch beantworten und dann machen wir
einmal so ein schokoladenkurs wie man
Kuvertüre richtig temperiert und dann
kann man da immer wieder nachschauen
und dann wird die Temperatur
kontrolliert nicht mit einem Thermometer
sondern einfach mit einer Teigkarte so
könnt ihr nämlich prüfen ob die
Kuvertüre schön fest wird das heißt ich
tauche jetzt gleich mit der Ecke einfach
nur ein leg dich hin und wenn es
innerhalb von 1 Minute schon schön fest
wird und ihr seht die bekommt einen
schönen Glanz dann ist sie perfekt dann
könnte ich sie weiter benutzen
die Karamell Kuvertüre die riecht so
lecker und sie ist voll lecker und die
ist auch muss ich sagen
ganz natürlich dieser dieser
Karamellgeschmack da wird nämlich
einfach bei der weißen Schokolade da ist
er keine keine Kakaomasse drin als
Praxis Kakaobutter aber so dieses
Kakaopulver das fehlt ja deswegen ist er
auch die die Kuvertüre dann weiß und bei
der Karamell Kuvertüre ist es dann
einfach so dass der Zucker der dazu
kommt vorher einfach karamellisiert wird
und dann kommt eben Kakaobutter dazu und
natürlich noch Milch mit rein oder
Milchpulver und dann entsteht eben
Karamell zu Rollade
[Musik]
während ich jetzt hier noch auf die
Probe kurz warte dann die Hütte hat noch
kurz Jobs Rose gekauft
das wird die noch kurz mit verwenden
können und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
nehme ich die Giotto Kugeln und Glitzer
Pulver Essbares Glitzerpulver
Lebensmittelfarbe und die können dir
dann in so einen Behälter geben
ein bisschen Gold dazu
und dann einfach schütteln und dann
bekommen die so ein Goldschimmer und ich
finde das schon sehr weihnachtlich
aber gerade darüber lachen müssen weil
die Jutta immer für unsere Rezept drehst
wenn ich dann sag Reichelsdorfer jetzt
ganz gut dann bist du schnell los und
kauft es und habe gesagt ihr denkt
wahrscheinlich alle Zärtlichkeiten.
wir sind nicht so eine Nacht Familie
vielleicht also Josch ist das schon
kurz mal nicht schön
[Musik]
und diese Krümelchen hier die benutze
ich auch gleich weiter
und dann könnt ihr die Kuvertüre in ein
großes hohes Gefäß Gießen ich nehme
jetzt einfachen dubbeglas
Pfälzer dubbeglas
damit ich die Cheats Text schon
eintragen kann wichtig ist jetzt dass
der Cheesecake kalt ist als er muss
nicht komplett durchgefroren aber
welches ein bisschen angefroren sein
wichtig ist auch dass alle Toppings
bereitstehen denn sobald ihr das jetzt
hier eintaucht und auf eine Backfolie
legt dann wird es einfach relativ
schnell fest
[Musik]
social abtropfen lassen
ups.de
und ein bisschen ab
dann kann sie ja drauf und dann können
die auch direkt die Toppings drauf geben
später werde ich noch wenn ich die weiße
Kuvertüre auch geschmolzen habe so ein
bisschen drüber Grübeln nennt man das so
ich nenn's einfach so
setzt dann einmal weg weil dann habe ich
diesen ganzen Schleier hier nicht und
dann könnt ihr solange die Kuvertüre
wirklich weich ist alles drauf geben
noch eine Kugel
[Musik]
und vielleicht setze ich auf ein paar
noch keine Gingerbread Männer
ja
und dann der Trödel und dann ach das
wird schon so gefällt mir gut
[Musik]
also Torte 1 ist jetzt fertig die sind
auch richtig hübsch aus wie gesagt da
fehlt mir doch das Rudel diese weiße
Kuvertüre aber die schmeiß ich ja jetzt
gleich und ihr seht auch ich habe
wirklich noch einiges am Kuvertüre übrig
aber ich brauche natürlich auch zum
Eintauchen wirklich viel die Kultur ist
aber nicht schlecht ich könnte jetzt in
Eiswürfelbehälter füllen und einfach
fest werden lassen dann raus drücken und
beim nächsten Mal verwenden oder ihr
nehmt die jetzt einfach und können z.b.
noch so kleine Silikonförmchen befüllen
und wir sind Pistazien rein oder
getrocknete Himbeeren und könnte dann so
kleine Pralinchen machen die auch
verschenken können also die könnt ihr
wirklich einfach ganz schön weiter
verwenden oder Schokocrossies machen
also da gibt's einfach ganz viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten Rocky Road
sind auch ganz gut also diese Kuvertüre
einfach immer schön weiter verwerten
oder direkt eben verpacken und beim
nächsten Mal benutzen damit sie kurz auf
und hole dann die weiße Kuvertüre für
die zweite Portion
ich habe überall Schokolade
so die zweite Version tauche ich jetzt
in weiße Kuvertüre und dann habe ich
hier noch Spekulatius bzw Lotus Kekse
zerkleinert mit ein bisschen goldpuder
nehmen dann auch die krisprolls in weiß
und Karamell auch die Giotto Kugeln und
die Gold Sterne und dann wird es eine
schöne Mischung
also ich finde die Cheesecake Steaks
sind in einer Farbe schon
nein
die sind schon so zwei Farben finde ich
sind perfekt ja so ein schönes Spiel
und dann immer wie gesagt kurz absetzen
und dann darüber
ich find einfach immer schön so eine
Kombi aus bröseln aus der großen Praline
dann ein paar krisprolls da hat nur so
ein bisschen was von allem
[Musik]
jetzt sind die Cheesecake Sticks fertig
und ich bin zumindest sehr zufrieden bin
ich mal gespannt ob der auch schmecken
heute darf Elisabeth probieren Elli du
hast noch nie vor deine operiert nee gar
nicht die Elite ist seit wie viel
Monaten 33 Monate Laufzeit
August bei uns im Team und sie kümmert
sich auch als ständige selber vor
und
zu
[Musik]
eine Bereicherung für Steven jetzt habe
ich hier Cheesecake sticky macht mega
schön auf und ich glaube als ich die
ersten Hacks Tricks gemacht habe da war
schön und da und da bin ich so richtig
eskaliert mit verschiedenen ich habe
gesehen Füllung Topping so und jetzt
habe ich gedacht mache ich sie mal
weihnachtlicher mega und was sind das
für welche Amazon Lebkuchen Käsekuchen
und und dann hier aber mit Karamell
Schokolade oder mit weißer Schokolade
auf
jeden Fall dieses Mal auch schön klein
und handlich gemacht ja gar nicht wir
haben wir die letzte Mal gegessen vom
Stuhl runter oder so angeschnitten ich
weiß ganz aber ist schon der Sinn
dahinter das nur das Haus Stiel essen
kann
Popcorn
Schokolade
total lecker und
[Musik]
ich finde das ist eine schöne Idee jetzt
kurz vor Weihnachten zum Verschenken
trotzdem relativ
also probiert das Rezept gerne aus wie
gesagt zu Weihnachten passen ihr könnt
die auch komplett anders gestalten und
so ein bisschen amerikanisch
weihnachtlich so grün rot gold mit
Zuckerstangen dekorieren macht einfach
top durchaus aber poste doch gerne eure
Ergebnisse auf Instagram oder Facebook
damit ich dir auch sehen kann da vorne
steht schon vor der Tür und will rein
mit die lassen jetzt gleich rein und ich
freue mich auf eure Cheesecake Sticks
markiert uns auf jeden Fall dass ich das
aufteilen kann viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss und die
Größe finde ich diesmal auch perfekt so
20 cm Durchmesser hat mir so eine schöne
Portion
rein
[Musik]